okay today I'm going to talk to you
about redox reactions so we're going to
have a look at a specific example we're
going to figure out what is being
reduced and what does that mean what is
being oxidized and what does that mean
and is there anything which is neither
being oxidized or reduced so what we've
got here is a nice displacement reaction
we've got chlorine reacting with
potassium iodide to give potassium
chloride and iodine so what we need to
do is we need to compare the different
atoms on this side of the equation in
our reactants with those in the product
and see how they've changed if at all so
whenever we're thinking about redox
we're thinking the term reduced and
oxidized that's why it's called redox
and we've got a really nice thing to
help us think about redox reactions
which is this acronym of
oil-rig oxidation is loss reduction is
gain now that's all very well to
remember we need to remember what does
it apply to and the answer is electrons
so if our particular atom is or ion has
gained electrons then it's going to be
reduction reduction is gain but if it's
lost them it's going to be oxidation
oxidation is loss so we're going to take
it one atom at a time and we're going to
figure out what's happened to it
so over here our chlorine that's just in
its element form so it hasn't gained or
lost any any electrons in order to be in
that state so it has no charge so in
within the reactants it starts off with
no charge so we've got to have a quick
think about it over here on the other
side now it's now in an ionic bond with
potassium now I know it's ionic because
it's between potassium which is a metal
and chlorine which is a nonmetal so a
potassium is given an electron to
chlorine so I know because chlorine is
in group seven in order to become an eye
on it
gains one electron to form a CL - ion
whereas our potassium because it's in
Group one it needs to lose one electron
to form an ion so if I have a look at
this here I can see what we end up with
here now we'll get we'll get on to
seeing what's happened to chlorine just
a minute before we do that let's figure
out what's going on with these other
different elements so potassium here now
potassium here is in an ionic bond with
iodine
so again potassium here is gonna form a
K plus ion iodine because it's in group
seven because it's in group seven it
forms a 1 minus ion so if it's in an
ionic bond here I know for a fact it's
got I - remember this is a metal
nonmetal we must have an ionic bond so
therefore that must be the two ions
involved on this side iodine is in its
element form so it's in an element form
it has no charge okay so what we've got
to do now is we've just got to have a
little look and try and figure out has
each one been oxidized has it been
reduced or has nothing happened to it at
all so let's start with our chlorine now
over here it has no charge here it now
has a negative charge so in order to go
from no charge to negative charge we
must have gained electrons because
remember gate electrons has a negative
charge
so if actually to form this chloride ion
we've gained electrons so therefore if
we have a look at this reduction is gain
then we must know this chlorine has been
reduced right next up let's have a look
at this iodine so the iodine starts off
negative and then it gets no charge so
we basically lost negativity so this one
has lost electrons to go from being
negative to having no charge if it's
lost electrons then it must be oxidized
now the final thing we're going to look
at is we're gonna have a look at this
potassium ion it starts off here with a
positive charge and it ends up here with
a positive charge as well so this
potassium here just gonna write this
down here so I've got a bit more space
this is called a spectator ion now what
that means is it hasn't been oxidized
because it hasn't lost any electrons it
hasn't been reduced because it hasn't
gained any electrons so therefore it's
referred to as a spectator ion this is
just an ion that does not go undergo
reduction or oxidation it just stays the
same from the reactants to the products
so that guy's is redox reactions
remember redox to do with reduction
oxidation remember oil-rig is to do with
oxidation is loss reduction is gain of
electrons then you need to think what
has happened to each of these different
elements involved remember if it's in an
ionic bond you've got to think carefully
does it form a positive so a positive
ion or does it form a negative ion then
you could figure out whether it's been
reduced or oxidized thank you very much